what are you gonna do with the money
like what do you need right Steve we had
a good meeting agree dolphins this
weekend so really you're on the right
side no all right one one piece of
advice for yours
[Music]
great meeting with Steve this morning
you know any time you're spending
obnoxious amounts of time with a
billionaire football owners who also
happen to be the greatest human beings
you're doing the right things good
morning good start gets me excited it
pumped up looking forward to it
vlog I love you guys
let's see how today goes I think I just
want to play until I die
you know and that's why I can see when
somebody likes it no matter what the
[ __ ] it is
once you love the game whatever that is
you win the problem is in
entrepreneurship especially modern day
entrepreneurship we do not celebrate the
game we're putting the riches on a
pedestal you have to love the game I
just don't know how you can be a
modern-day CPG business and not have a
disproportionate strategy on Amazon
Walmart Saints bury Teske you know
direct-to-consumer Facebook Instagram
conversion like all this stuff is just
so important how one can be a common
sense individual in 2018 and not start
putting real effort towards building
those capabilities even if you're losing
money on your P&L and the short term to
build up those capabilities blows my
mind I am pumped that I'm doing an
interview and will be on the record I
want to be on the record that the lack
of effort both mentally and financially
into direct-to-consumer capabilities is
the reason the majority of the fortune
500 CPG brands will be in massive
decline a decade from this interview
it's the chase it's the process it's the
game
and your energy consistently is kinetic
towards this thing that I think is going
to make you make the decisions that
won't let you get to the thing all right
don't have another call but I have a
call two minutes ago Tyler's not on top
of schedule the same way I am that needs
to be discussed more on the vlog I'm
super sharp you know that's that's you
know what you you know what must be
disheartening you're so busy visiting an
almost every single person watching this
the problem is it's that when I'm
catching it you know you're not busier
than me so there's that there's you've
been suffocated out of the excuse that
would make so much sense to everybody
else the problem is it's me that's doing
the catching yeah it's heartbreaking out
here this is Gary Vaynerchuk what's up
dude you look cool with glasses
mayonnaise that actually was kind of
caught me off guard
I genuinely think you look much better
the fact they help you to see and you're
better-looking and cooler like I didn't
actually really for a hundredth of a
second looking down recognize you and
I'm like who's that good-looking big man
changed yes sir
look at who's here talking about a
handsome man
this is Long Island accent comes out
when he performs in the camera followed
up with people on Instagram obviously
not your VIPs not the people my inbox
the people in the Instagram go through
everyone who has replied like Gary just
asked me to check in and I'll come over
the top how many have filled out 55 lip
speakers I'm excited 55 once you I just
went back through our social rank of
everybody that has 50 to 100k followers
there's more people that we didn't pick
a hundred thousand and up so I'd like to
find five minutes do that one more time
with you and I'll be direct oh cool I
mean 50 is getting into territory where
I'm not sure I want to do that well I'm
a punch miss [ __ ] face Benji kicks
I'm gonna punch your [ __ ] face if you
don't follow me cool all right
cool a professional athlete is scary to
me you live your whole life you're
growing up you're gonna be this and by
American standards for athletes
somewhere in your 30s you're done and
then you're lost that's why it's fun to
see the young athletes want to be
entrepreneurs because they're all gonna
have a lot more to do I genuinely
believe that I sabotage my wealth to
string out my game I'm in it for the
game why don't I like the Yankees and
the Rangers anymore they'd won now I
only like the Knicks in the
Jetts it's the chase it's the process
it's the game my man hustle boy it's
crazy what's up this is it you need to
send me the Jersey to put in here man I
do some you know I just need my gun
yeah semi one yeah 25 Arizona I love you
yes Kevin Rhodes the best and your
energy consistently is kinetic towards
this thing that I think is gonna make
you make the decisions that won't let
you get to the thing my chase of the New
York Jets by eating the [ __ ] 18 hours a
day is the lifestyle and we have 95% of
the market believing that the lifestyle
is you do something to get the fun stuff
and it's the 5% that understand the
process is the fun stuff that get to buy
the 95% of stuff got it you got it
brother
that was just synthesized to this whole
game there's this thought that you yeah
and then yeah mm-hmm the whole thing has
to be a whether results in dollars that
are here up here up here unless you're
in that yeah the whole way you're
finished if you're gonna you're finished
I think a lot of people graduate from
ice cream to a vacation home yeah I
think people are caught in the game I
think people are confused man like to me
the process of making that cake is
interesting the thought of like can I
buy the eggs for a good deal can I
create a flavor of carrot cake mix with
mint chocolate chip that nobody's ever
done before can I be remembered for
making great cake but you're also not
afraid to be wrong rat is damn right
you're not afraid to be I'm not great
and I also will own it if I'm wrong I
love being wrong because I love the game
and if I was wrong that means the game
is pure of course that's the best part
and I didn't need it
like 20s so I could buy a yacht to get
girls I'm not that insecure and
insecurity is what's hurting some well
it's also it depends what you want
if yes slot is the yacht and the girls
you can do that and you know what by the
way as a dude sounds fun yeah Jake wants
it bad
Jake Jake okay let's go the next
question was amazing bad
[Music]
it's a blog super-intense day a lot of
meetings I don't know what iris is gonna
get out of it but heading to the digital
uncorked it's a new concept that
vaynermedia has created a lot of people
a lot of people aren't in place
financially where they want to invest in
the four DS $10,000 consulting project
so we created a more intimate fund it's
good obviously much shorter version and
not unusually me instead of the
vaynermedia staff so we created
something called digital for $2,000
business dinner Ahmet and I'm heading
there for the first one so I'm excited
about a kind of new world that we're
involved in and should be interesting to
see how we can deliver a lot of value in
this environment so we'll see what's up
you know I know a lot of you came for
the business stuff but if we can achieve
anything for me because I have so much
love for it is the platform that my
family my family basically on the
platform of wine made it in America so I
have a lot of emotion for it if I can
get you to try new things that would be
such a remarkable accomplishment son
Sears especially interesting to me
because I do think that people that do
like white wine tend to get into
Chardonnay and drink it over and over
and over
what's cool about Sun sear and maybe
you're seeing this is it's not super
heavy but it's super crisp and complex
so it's interesting and not boring like
a lot of average white wine that's light
and what-have-you but more importantly
it is an incredibly flexible wine when
it comes to food
so what its ability to do with fish and
salads and light fare and by itself is
super interesting to me so I hope you
enjoyed it comes to a really good
producer it's super clean if you're an
oysters and clams and shellfish fan like
I am like this is a hardcore pairing for
that world so keep that in mind if you
want to nerd it up or take a note and
then finally I want you guys to do
something with all the wines we have
tonight which is sniffy snippet and
here's what I mean by that the core
thing that you can do to really get into
wine is make sure you smell it like and
I don't mean the this smell that seems
like kind or cordial I
getting your whole schnoz in there and
really smelling it I've seen a lot of
you tastes wines both the red and white
already if you've tasted it normal if
you can now smell it hardcore and then
taste it again it'd be interesting to
see if you felt that it tasted different
than it did one minute ago I think for a
lot of you you'll be really taken aback
on how extreme the flavor profiles can
be when you do that so I want I want to
allow you to do that so in the fame of
tonight I want to do a lot of QA so I
kind of created my two frameworks I
walked around the first forethought I'll
finish off in a little bit but I'd like
to open up the mic again I think that a
lot of you have a ton of context so I'm
willing to go anywhere answer anything
from any of your business questions
hopes aspirations I'm thrilled to talk
New York Jets football whatever you want
to go and talk about I'm here so who's
got a question one more time what's your
what's your goal in like black and white
what do you think your goal is everybody
thinks that revenues a proxy of course
so why that number but what I want to
you know what I'm most worried about
and there are a couple interactions you
I feel like you're coming up with
arbitrary things
why not 700 wine at least 9,000 why is
it a 500 can it be 150 the [ __ ] what
does that all mean do you understand
yeah like I don't think that's the right
way to think about it from my
perspective I could be wrong but like I
think it has no actual grounding I
wanted to buy a sports franchise when I
was little and the romantic part I
learned English and I get it it's cute I
liked it but it was because I wanted to
make such a big goal so that I could
keep playing forever
getting to 500 employees is gonna be
done real quick if you're good enough
then what but you don't want to be as an
athlete a professional athlete is scary
to me you live your whole life you're
growing up you're gonna be this and by
American standards for athletes
somewhere in your 30s you're done and
then you're lost that's why it's fun to
see the young athletes want to be
entrepreneurs because they're all gonna
have a lot more to do it's an arbitrary
number reach pay very close attention to
my goal my goal is so ridiculous when
you start trying to rush to 500 you
start over hiring when you don't need it
because it means like you're getting
closer to 500 but having a hundred
thirteen or 157 means no [ __ ] real
difference if you want the money that
means you want to buy something if you
like I like when people say to me
believe it or not it's not about the
money I'm like uh-huh like it may be the
ego of the number because at dinner you
want to tell your best friend it's now
13 instead of 8 maybe I get that I
understand that I don't know but like
what are you gonna do with the money
like what do you need the reason there's
so few people that actually get the
things because they're the ones who are
purebred don't give a [ __ ] about the
things P or bred naturally I didn't
manifest this I didn't force this I
didn't read a book it came natural to me
to not want anything you need to really
figure yourself out because once you
figure stuff out you're cruising you
start rolling
once you figure yourself out nobody has
leverage on you because once you
understand yourself you start putting
yourself in positions to not let a lap
people have leverage on you and I don't
want to let you do that you know
it's super heavy but reach it's good
stuff you know what I mean you have to
go to that next place because you're
just throwing things at the wall and I
get it the problem is it's gonna feel
real empty when you get there and then
when you love the game five hundred and
twenty forty seven just all goes away it
all gets real slow
I'm really glad you guys came out
tonight
[Music]
good event
I don't like when the rock produces me
so well I risk avast iris could've asked
I don't like what the rock produces me I
loved when iris produces me my outro
isn't this great [ __ ] night of the
content in this event the straight
[ __ ] fire and all three of you know
it
[Music]
you
[Music]